I want to play a quick game with you
grown ashore childish oh okay okay I
like that I've never heard that taking
naps is that brownish or droppage took
it up yesterday naps promise absolutely
recovery time
naps and absent like hair not in hair
naps as in sleep
oh that's groaning you got a prioritize
like you got to recharge UV we use out
in the real world all day dealing with
other people's stuff a man taking that
escape reality for a second because what
he wake up is still happy still there
it's still there but also childish
because kids is be eating burping and
going bag so we hmm
get your ass up
[Music]
crying in public listen sometimes stuff
hits the fan uh-huh and bad things can
happen it so once in a while if that
happens I mean listen you don't want to
be crying in public so I'm gonna say
childish but there are exceptions to
every rule that's a hard one because you
know it don't go through things too
sometimes
and it's okay to let it out I'm very
sensitive I only let it show in front of
people I'm comfortable with so if you're
around people who you don't want to see
you cry just go in the bathroom I go to
the bathroom
crying in public childish how you're
grown contain yourself you've lived
enough to just be able to just bottle it
up come on Bob serious bottle it up you
have all these other places to cry
you're gonna cry in public for other
people to see that we don't want to see
that and I gotta be true to me so if
there's a situation where I really felt
like my god okay well it was a serious
sir give me a minute
what hurt so bad
[Music]
is it groaning a childish to cuddle with
your parents
childish what you mean like I'd be mad
I'd be mad affectionate with my parents
okay but I ain't gonna sleep with him in
cuddle I'm grown I got my own bed I want
to have him on MySpace I'm asleep cuddle
with my parents but I think that would
be really sweet if I had a grown child
and they wanted to cuddle with me I
probably like it I don't know if you
would or not it's childish how older
your current age I'm definitely not
actually I'm not gonna lie like if I'm
caught up like on the couch of someone
might cover like oh my mom when I was
little she's been calling for Pusa she
was way like this and I was like being
the crevice here her butt would be the
pillow now that was childish you know
sometimes I'm in the cuddling mode
sometimes my mom might not be she said
Chloe it's hot right now not right now
but I can't that is college and child I
think you're never too old cutta cutta
cuddling with your parents oh no you're
gonna get everything okay slurping your
drink in public nope that's let's just
no there's no place for that there is a
point childish or groaning that's okay
that's just it just slurping your drink
drink you drink you don't mean to you
know I do it no I do it cuz like at the
bottom of the cup when it goes does that
consider me grown as your childish
powder let's say
[Music]
watching cartoons about groaning
groaning what cartoons are you watching
oh there are so many groaners cartoons
now Rick and Morty Bojack horseman all
of these really good adult cartoons yeah
okay okay let me let me back up then
still groaning because I watch Dragon
Ball super like nobody's business
[Music]